[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 22
février europe connexion en
représentation au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 25
février écrit par alexandra badea le
trait le texte retrace l'ascension et le
burn out d'un assistant parlementaire
devenu lobbyiste et du côté des rayons
de librairies le 22 février sans le
grand gâchis culturel
un ouvrage écrit par le maire de
versailles françois de mazières et
olivier le naire journaliste à l'express
il dresse un tableau alarmant
marion et sylvie breton travaille autour
du tissu elle ne crée qu'à partir
d'objets de récupération qu'elle expose
depuis le 16 février à l'hôtel de ville
de guyancourt on débute donc avec du
théâtre la compagnie du veilleur est de
retour sur la scène nationale du théâtre
du théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
cette fois elle présente europe
connexion la pièce a été créée il ya
quelques mois à taïwan le public peut
découvrir l'ascension et la chute d'un
assistant parlementaire européen devenu
lobbyiste une oeuvre critique et parfois
cynique ancrée pour l'actualité
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude tu as pris le chemin
classique un stage au parlement un stage
à la commission assistant parlementaire
auprès d'une députée commission
environnement santé publique et sécurité
alimentaire ça car il a toujours rêvé
d'être lobbyistes encore un lent auprès
de sa députée puis le défendra notamment
les pesticides avec europe annexion
alexandra badea écrit sur les enjeux de
santé publique que mathieu roy met en
scène
manière de parler d'un fait de société
politique et économique très important
aujourd'hui et alexandra badea le fait
d'une manière très mature gic très
intéressante et très fort d'un point de
vue théâtre c'est important aussi que le
théâtre s'empare de ces phénomènes de
société pour raconter des histoires et
évidemment faire prendre conscience aux
spectateurs de l'urgence de changer nos
modes de production et de fonctionnement
notamment dans notre consommation
alimentaire de tous les jours 10 micro
saynète jouée en français et en mandarin
des saynètes qui s'enchaînent sans répit
comme le fournissement du parlement
européen
le spectateur vit avec les personnages
c'est un rapport de spectateurs immersif
où on va mettre les spectateurs sur le
plateau du théâtre dans un rapport
quadri frontale c'est à dire qu'ils sont
de part et d'autre des quatre faces de
la scénographie et les spectateurs vont
pouvoir regarder ce qui va se passer
sous leurs yeux en étant assez proche
des comédiens à la fois par le casque
audio qui vont mettre sur leurs oreilles
et puis aussi par la proximité physique
puisque les acteurs sont à 50 cm à 1 m 2
un casque pour entendre les pensées du
lobbyisme un jeune homme qui voit petit
à petit le piège se refermer sur lui une
métaphore du burn out europe connexion
est une pièce fictive qui prend parfois
des aspects documentaires
tu aurais pu mettre ton intelligence
dans des causes plus nobles
tu aurais pu faire de la recherche
tu aurais pu écrire des bouquins tu
aurais pu éclairer le monde
mais tout ça ne t'aurais pas donné tout
ce pouvoir
on reste au théâtre mais dans un style
complètement différent le collectif la
boue et se lance un défi réaliser un
spectacle à empreinte carbone zéro
les comédiens recycle tous les costumes
les décors mais aussi les textes des
textes absurdes où se côtoient molière
rue goethe et musset regardez cet
extrait un royaume sur ans d'études une
réelle
princesse à marier un prince pour fort
riche a marié tient donc un traître d'un
temps dans une coquette qui passait par
là marié sur leur temps ont prétendu
arrive aujourd'hui quoi comme gidouille
je veux me marier je suis très avoir la
poesy une brillante idée une idée super
une vengeance pire sans ce jeudi 23
février sort en librairie un ouvrage
écrit par le député-maire françois
mazères député maire de versailles
il s'appelle le grand gâchis culturel un
ouvrage écrit en collaboration avec le
journaliste olivier le naire et qui
dresse un tableau plutôt alarmant de la
situation du monde culturel
à quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle une présentation de
l'ouvragé s'est faite mardi 21 février à
paris un reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch et alice deschamps un titre
sans équivoque et un constat sans
ambiguïté des budget sabré des
intermittents fragiliser un patrimoine
abandonné
françois de mazières et olivier le naire
respectivement aux hommes politiques de
droite et journaliste de gauche partage
dans ce nouvel ouvrage la même position
sur le monde culturel français un sujet
et trans partisan est une priorité
nationale pour les deux auteurs on pense
tous les deux que jamais on arrivera à
sortir des ornières dans lesquelles nous
sommes si on n'arrive pas à récupérer la
question culturelle à la remettre au
centre et ça c'est un combat qui est de
droite de gauche de tout ce qu'on voudra
et c'est d'abord un combat pas des
politiques mais des citoyens réveillez
le monde culturel à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle françois de
mazières décline ainsi dix propositions
le député maire de versailles
historiquement engagé sur la thématique
culturelle lui le créateur du festival -
molière un événement une cité qui fêtera
cette année ses 21 ans il faut être fier
d'un héritage qui est le nôtre
la france est une ville d'un pays de
culture la france réputation
internationale dans ce domaine
eh bien il faut l'entretenir et c'est
vrai versailles c'est pas si vous voulez
ce que j'ai fait qu'il est à mettre en
avant c'est que versailles incarne aux
yeux du monde la culture française et
donc voit aujourd'hui avec mon équipe
municipale
j'ai une mission j'ai un devoir c'est
d'essayer de faire encore rayonner la
culture à versailles le grand gâchis
culturel sort en librairie ce mercredi
22 février aux éditions albin michel
elles font de la récup dollar marion et
sylvie breton créé autour de l'univers
du tissu depuis le 16 février l exposé à
l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt des
lustres ferdinand fils ou encore en
boutons l'une de ses oeuvres créées
pendant des ateliers sera présenté le 9
mars prochain lors du vernissage
[Musique]
le djinn découpé entre la ces matières
premières de cette reconstruction
une pièce pensé par marion et sylvie
breton est créé avec d'aiguillon
courtois volontaire là on est vraiment
premier atelier
c'est une base de départ qui bombent à
l'idée c'était un petit peu d'habiller
le l'escalier de la mairie à guyancourt
celle aussi l'usure du temps c'est
malgré tout même si on n'en récupère
beaucoup actuellement c'est un certain
un objet de travail c'est un vêtement de
travail et
il est d'une texture intéressant d'une
texture qui s'usent d'une texture que
tout le monde porte
si grand la pièce rejoindra le 9 mars
l'exposition déjà en cours à l'hôtel de
ville
si cette lustres majestueux imposant
trônant sur la mezzanine des pièces
uniques et différentes décline en tissus
et matériaux comme on travaille beaucoup
avec la notion de recyclage et de
retravailler la matière l'art transforme
et c'est une matière qui permet d d d
des effets assez incroyable et un fini
les lustres pour nous c'est un objet à
la fois qu'ils n'étaient identifiables
comme c'est à la fois une sculpture un
objet décoratif
ça n'a aucune utilité montre et on
l'aimé bien et c'est un très beau volume
ça permet et c'est quelque chose qui
parle à tous enfin j'allais
illustre sa objet le bel objet par
excellence des cravates des boutons des
bobines de fil des pièces de la
manufacture bowe dernière entreprise
d'épingler française un thème par
lustres pour une plongée dans la petite
histoire du textile une autre exposition
autour du filet du tissu cette fois
c'est aux clayes-sous-bois céline louve
et matérialise l'ambiguïté de l'enfance
ses oeuvres sont à découvrir jusqu'au 19
mars prochain
le coup de coeur cinéma de cette semaine
est signée cyril adan de l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois
regarder cette semaine notre coup de
coeur et le film jackie de pablo l'arène
avec natalie portman 22 novembre 1963
john fitzgerald kennedy
35e président des états unis vient
d'être assassiné à dallas confrontés à
la violence de son deuil sa veuve
jacqueline bouvier kennedy first lady
admiré par son élégance et sa culture
tente d'en surmonter le traumatisme
décidé à mettre en lumière d'héritage
politique du président et à célébrer
l'homme qui tue les gens aiment croire
en conte de fées je me suis habitué
fossé entre ce que tout le monde croit
ce que je sais être la vérité
je ne suis plus la première dame vous
pouvez m'appeler jacques après neruda
pablo larrain récidive avec ce nouveau
film en évoquant de façon intense et
émouvante la tragédie de dallas il offre
à natalie portman le rôle de jackie
kennedy qu'elle interprète de façon
magistrale avec force sobriété et
émotion le film réussit à mêler à la
fois les souffrances intimes de la femme
et la force de la première dame face au
destin
ce biopic réussit aussi bien à nous
tirer des larmes qu'elle nous rendre
admiratif du courage de cette femme
ce réalisateur apporte une nouvelle fois
la preuve qui est l'un des plus doués de
sa génération
jha qui est à découvrir en version
originale et version française cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]
avant de nous quitter quelques rendez
vous à noter on ne présente plus les
wampas et leurs titres rock coloré et
faussement naïfs ils sortent un nouvel
album et seront sur la scène de la
batterie à guyancourt
le 25 février prochain on regarde un
extrait
[Musique]
à
grand écart musical on parle de musique
classique les 24es février 26 février
prochain l'opéra royal de versailles
accueille cecilia bartoli la grande
cantatrice italienne interprétera le
rôle de cenerentola la cendrillon de re
signer regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
à tisser le plus célèbre opéra de lully
le fondateur de l'opéra français et
musiciens du roi soleil
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles fait revivre son nez son
esprit caustique et bouffon la première
représentation française se rattrape le
2 mars prochain et le plasticien bernard
rancillac exposé à partir du 25 février
à la maison elsa triolet aragon
l'artiste rend compte à sa manière de
l'actuelle de l'actualité de notre monde
il dérange le confort et la bienséance
de l'univers de l'art
les études culture est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis et je vous dis à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]